mrs. in declaration for Easter brain
stream where's my Eagle County
constituency the electrolytic estate for
distinction see for this relation was et
3205 the total votes cast Malaysian with
60,000 603 the percentage of total votes
cast is therefore 72.8 percent there
were 64 by kinkos rejected so I Lindsey
feelin returning officer freaky
parliamentary general election the
Easter break extremely and lastly the
Eagle County constituency hereby give
notice the total number of votes told
for each candidate a narration was as
close dr. Lisa cabin in the Scottish
National Party 33,000
daddy 3678 join mystery independent 300
meeting maker mechanics courses waiver
party 17,100
all I got a gorgeous little Democrats
Wednesday's with 42 rocio ET
Independence Party 1221 cream Simpson
Scottish conservative and unionist party
7129 I in favor of the visa Cameron is
therefore a way to sell ET feminine as a
neighbor for easter babe
many thymosin many times i must mission
Matthias to returning officer staff on
the police for the professional pointer
to the cake thanks also to the other
candidates read excellent election
German including a number of enjoyable
us things to be I want to side my agent
in Macau
and the fantastic team in SNP of this
construction
if it has made all of this possible many
times to to my husband mark on my new my
name's Olivia I'm Charlotte for their
unending support
most of all I would like to thank the
people of this instead chances of
easterbridge straighten analyzing legal
for placing their faith in me for their
faith and the message of our First
Minister Nicola Sturgeon and for their
faith in the Scottish National Party I
have sought to conduct a positive
campaign that reflects the style
politics that people see whether you
voted 18 key or not today and whatever
your views on Scotland scripture i will
seek to represent everybody in this
institution see to the very best of my
ability i am to be an accessible mp4 its
people's needs first and foremost this
election is fundamentally about making
the voice of this institution see and
the full of Scotland cared more
effectively at Westminster
I will do everything that I can to build
unity as I bought by this important task
that you have entrusted me with as an
NHS doctor and consulting clinical
psychologist for 20 years I have all
served the public in manchuria i will
pledge to protect our NHS and to serve
you in my new role i will use my voice
not just into Scotland but to pursue
together politics for the benefit of the
people across the United Kingdom and
tonight I have been elected alongside a
strong group of SNP and peace
we will work to put an end to the
identity cups which are hurting people
in our communities across Scotland and
in the rest of the UK we will call for
the Pirates promise to Scotland in the
referendum starting with those which
makes the biggest impact in getting more
people into work Anna making work pay by
agency edited and strapping giant we can
choose to invest in children and protect
the things that really matter to the
people of Scotland Scotland unless
constituency are speaking loudly and
clearly tonight we are unified and it is
time for a voice to be here at waist
Minister
tonight Scotland is entrusting the SNP
to create a new beginning in Westminster
politics a new beginning with social
justice firmly at its core thank you